les véhicules blindés Canadiens
commandés par le gouvernement haïtien
sont arrivés à l'aéroport de
Port-au-Prince sous le regard aiguisé de
résidents qui ont capté la scène avec
leur appareil
était prévu depuis des mois
[Applaudissements]
l'équipement servira à soutenir la
Police nationale d'Haïti la PNH qui a
perdu le contrôle de la capitale
gangrené par des gangs lourdement armés
la PNA fait débordée elle a besoin de
plus de moyens et l'envoi de ces blindés
là va justement renforcer la capacité de
la PH à faire son travail le cœur du
pays est secoué par les manifestations
ou les violences et la légitimité du
Premier ministre Ariel Henry et contesté
depuis un an les États-Unis ont déjà
déclaré qu'ils sont prêts à renforcer
leur présence sur le plan humanitaire
après la demande d'aide militaire du
gouvernement haïtien
entrevue au coulisses du pouvoir
l'ambassadeur du Canada en Haïti
rappelle kotawa a investi des millions
pour renforcer la PNH et que la solution
à la crise passe par la police haïtienne
mais cette année même aussi il y a eu
des annonces qui ont été faites environ
42 millions de dollars en nouvelle
contribution pour la PNH pour nous la
solution durable au problème de sécurité
en Haïti c'est le renforcement de la
Police nationale d'Haïti cette livraison
fait planer le spectre d'une
intervention étrangère mal perçue d'une
partie de la population qui en garde un
mauvais souvenirs
étrangères allaient foulées le soleil
sien explique ce manifestant
malheureusement oui dans une situation
où on essaie de choisir la moins pire
des solutions et quelle est la moins
pire des solutions est-ce que c'est une
intervention par une force
multinationale dont dans le fond ni les
Haïtiens ni la communauté international
ne souhaite essentiellement d'une part
ou bien est-ce qu'on laisse les gens
continuent à souffrir
le secrétaire général des Nations Unies
est en faveur du déploiement immédiat
d'une force multinationale le Conseil de
sécurité doit se réunir la semaine
prochaine au sujet d'Haïti ici Mélissa
François Radio-Canada Montréal